you know what amazes me when you were
leaving saturday night live
mick jagger is the host which is amazing
yeah
and it's your last show and mick comes
out
and is singing leading the whole cast to
say goodbye to you on the last show
it gives me the chills i wasn't there
but it gives me the chills mick jagger
starts singing she's a rainbow
she's a rainbow to you and then ruby
[Music]
tuesday i know why
little chills now too yeah right i mean
and then each cast member comes up and
dances with you
colin jost actually wrote that piece
and we did it at read through because
usually uh when someone leaves you there
there's like a goodbye sketch at read
through and it's a lot of it's sort of
just like
you know it can be like an inside joke
thing just kind of like a funny thing
that you read at the end of the day and
everyone's crying and it's
you know and he wrote the sketch and we
and we did it and i danced with everyone
and i you know it was
uh very emotional and it was beautiful
when i heard it was gonna be in the show
i was like oh my and it almost wasn't
because we were like running out of time
and
um i had to that was like one of my
fastest
changes i've ever had to do and it was
one of the best moments of
my life yeah i imagine
and then lauren comes out and starts
dancing with you
i'm like who the hell gets this i mean
that is some send-off and and i was
thinking
it's kind of a dangerous precedent
because not everyone is going to get
that kind of send
off i mean yeah people people have had
you know amazing
send-offs on the show um but
i i don't know i i feel
really lucky and foo fighters were there
and foo fighters which
was really cool because foo fighters uh
they were
the musical guest on my very first show
so
they like wrapped it up um and
that was pretty amazing and then like
steve martin is randomly up there too
and
he was why are you close with steve i
mean i've
i've worked with him many times i i love
him he was there he just showed up
yeah and amy was there and jon hamm was
there
and i didn't watch it though for a long
time because i was scared to watch it
because i knew i would cry